vielleicht suchen wir einen kuchen aus
okay so was willst du von kuchen und mit
smarties smarties und dann schokolade
das mit so einem regenbogen mit
marshmallows magst du manchmal los und
schokolade
mit ganz viel glück
[Musik]
das ist was hat das angela wie startet
denn einzel video wie starte ich immer
mit hallo
herzlich willkommen zur welt wir backen
heute einen geburtstagskuchen mehr hat
morgen geburtstag und wie alt wirst du
und du hast dir einen kuchen gewünscht
wie soll der aussehen
[Musik]
also packen wir dich jetzt zusammen okay
dann sag mal die zutaten die wir
brauchen
da ist alles drin
oder war zumindest auf eine chance trägt
ja das ist kein wasser das ja was ist
das
mit cacau krass der moment wenn dein
kind die zutat richtig ausspricht und du
selber nicht sagte wacker und sie sagt
einfach khaki und was ist das zum
schluss
[Musik]
backpulver damit der kuchen stehen auf
geht ok leider darf jetzt anfangen
schatzi und zwar genau möchte kurz okay
du hast du schon rein und dann kommt
noch genauer löffel raus ja und jetzt
salz und zucker hier der ganze
zuckerschock darauf alles rein und ein
bisschen ganz wenige ganz wenig über
kuchen und jetzt hören wir und man darf
da nicht rein fassen
ja ich finde es jetzt gerade mich aber
jetzt darfst du an machen und nicht mit
den händen reihen und nicht mit den
haaren
dann holte verschafft vielleicht werden
heute noch fertig vielleicht doch nicht
jetzt waren die zutaten einfach schön
cremig verrührt und ich kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die erste schälen
fein raspeln und ella ist sollen ihre
kippen
[Musik]
gute aus
wahnsinn dass man noch kurz
aha
[Musik]
ok so weiter fakten oder willst deine
pizza essen weiter warten
guck mal hier
dass hier ein damit wir sie eben können
da kommt es am nil dazu das ist dass man
ja gut das kommt jetzt erst machen
[Musik]
möchtest du das da rein machen
mathematisch nur den deckel unten weg
weißt du wie das weiß wie lang sie
erwarte trockenen zutaten dazu sieben
und die äpfel die geriebenen besonders
öl das gehen wir also mit rein
[Musik]
wenn du jetzt alles schreckt ist dann
von oben an opa nix mehr morgen an
seinem geburtstag ja bis jetzt schön die
pizza heinz schmeckt
okay das öl darf jetzt auch mit rein und
die äpfel nicht vergessen
ich mache mich bisschen helfen
ok ich helf dir bisschen okay jetzt kann
man das früher
so perfekt ja ich habe ein halbes kilo
teig in dir drin
und wie schmeckt gut hab sie mir gab's
den daumen nach oben gegeben
achille emana der teig ist ein bisschen
fest
wir geben noch etwas milch dazu ok ich
schreibe auch jetzt rezept also wir
fügen noch bisschen milch dazu denn der
ist echt noch ein bisschen fest
und dann habe ich jetzt hier schon
unsere backform einen tortenring den
stelle ich auf 26 cm und schlag den
faktor 4 1 damit eben der flüssige teig
nicht ausläuft schlagring doch nicht ein
denn das ist ja gar nicht so flüssig
also war krieg drauf bisschen wenig in
den teig ja ist einfach mein kind kriegt
sonst nie was zu essen
und wenn es dann mal was kriegt dann ja
dann überträgt so ist der teig gut
erinnern dass man jetzt einfach so etwa
40 gramm
und jetzt kommt der teig hier rein und
dann in den backofen und ab in den
backofen gewachsen
a
[Musik]
ist ein apfel du bist nicht nur selbst
wenn du hunger hast ist ein apfel
ich habe dir dich zwei wochen links
gegessen
ella ist jetzt in der malschule für eine
stunde der kuchen ist im backofen und
ich habe mir gedacht wenn wir diesen
regenbogen kuchen machen machen wir noch
welchen er hat sich zwar gewünscht dass
wir da marshmallows hinsetzen
aber ich werde jetzt noch was anderes
mit dazu machen nämlich so kleine kokos
welchen ohne zusätzlichen zucker also
ich versuche jetzt wirklich auf die
natur süße zurückzugreifen und verwendet
daher für die cocos bällchen geschälte
mandeln davon habe ich jetzt 50 gramm 50
gramm apfelringe die sind getrocknet 80
gramm kokosraspeln 250 gramm magerquark
oder etwas vanille extrakt gugelmann
electric wir sind zu betreuen
aber ist ja gar nicht schlimm ich finde
sowieso ich habe mir lange überlegt wie
mache ich jetzt dieses kuchenrezepte
eller vor allem auch von kindergarten
und viele haben sich auch immer
gewünscht rezepte ohne zucker ich habe
jetzt diesen kuchen gemacht mit etwas
weniger zucker aber ich finde kinder
müssen halt auch wissen ein kuchen ist
eine süßigkeit und ich darf ab und zu
mal ein stückchen essen aber eben nicht
so viel und ich stehe ganz ehrlich gar
nicht so sehr auf zuckerersatzstoffe die
eben null kalorien haben oder kam ich
auch mal bieten sogar benutzt oder kokos
blüten zucker aber gerade chorus böden
sogar der auch kalorien und ich glaube
man darf einfach nicht den kindern den
eindruck vermitteln
es ist jetzt gesund und deswegen darfst
du mehr essen also sage ich immer lieber
ist so ein bisschen weniger und davon
handelt
daneben abzumachen stück genau bei denen
habe ich jetzt gedacht wird jetzt alles
schön feine gemüse
der akku ist leer
marco morath in der küche ja mehr
technik ok ich hole einen anderen mixa
als gedacht dass emma weg gibt mache
ganz geschwind hier die bildschirme nein
sehr schön da kommen jetzt die
apfelringe dazu ihr könnt da auch
staffeln zum beispiel aprikosen nehmen
oder andere früchte
ich habe jetzt die äpfel weil die
einfach schön hell sind und eben auch
eine tolle zusammen mit zerkleinern
ja das wird schon wieder so ein bisschen
mit weil ich hab' ich habe es noch nicht
ausprobiert da kommet die kokosflocken
mit rein
es gebe ich die masse ich hier in eine
schüssel und verlor sie noch mit dem
vanille extrakt und mit dem quark ist
hier verrühren
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt nochmal 50 gramm mehr
kokosflocken und 80 gramm aprikosen und
stets kleiner ich jetzt einfach und
thermisch das auch verzichten und ist
gut
er hätte das schmeckt sie wirklich dass
er lügt gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das ist gott
ja richtig schöne formbare masse jetzt
nämlich den kleinen eis funktionäre
immer so eine kleine kugel vom sinn der
hand und wählen sie dann nochmal den
kokons raspeln und das war es wichtig
ist dass ihr diese kokos kugel dann auf
jeden fall im kühlschrank lagert den der
quark drin und dann sollten sie auf
jeden fall gekühlt werden
[Musik]
smart tees kaputt was machen wir jetzt
damit noch gut ja die backen basteln so
stark weil du ist verstaubt ist schon
alt also ela du studierst du jetzt nach
farben ja die smarties die braunen die
brauchen wir nicht aber die bunten die
brauchen mehr
ich habe jetzt hier noch mit ghanas
gemacht denn er hat sich eine
schokotorte gewünscht ja da habe ich ja
schon immer mal
daher habe ich jetzt hier 150 gramm
sahne und 300 gramm zucker schokolade zu
dieser ganz verarbeitet also einfach
sahne aufkochen lassen schokolade zu
rühren fertig und der kuchen da ist ja
auch gebacken den habe ich jetzt schon
im kühlschrank damit ich hier jetzt
besser schneiden kann den kuchen löse
getraut
keiner weiß was auch voll lecker ist
bananen schokoladenkuchen ist auch
leckere ich halte jetzt den kuchen
[Musik]
meiste wasser damit er richtig schön
schokoladig wird schneide ich denn jetzt
hier noch mal durch und dann fühlen wir
dann auch noch mit der schokolade okay
ja die machen wir dann obendrauf
jetzt kommt ihr die ghanas reihen
das sieht man auch schön die
apfelstückchen und dadurch ist der
kuchen echt schön saftig dann ob mir das
jetzt bisschen zu vereinfachen werde ich
denn jetzt hier gerade recht
ich hab nicht geschummelt
sagt mir ein schwieriges kind ja gerade
übernimmst du meinen kanal
ja ja wann machst du den suezkanal
selber dann kann die mama kann sich
hinsetzen und kann dir zu gucken ja
machst du dann mit samira zusammen denn
sallys kanal ok jetzt hat sich alle
torten teile hier drauf und jetzt am
besten mit dem boden als abschluss da
haben wir einen schönen geraten kuchen
gut hier hinten fehlt noch ein bisschen
was man auch schon mal jetzt einfach was
rein guckt so dass da geht hier so ein
bisschen runter dann heben wir das hier
noch mal ansetzen ein stück teig rein
und fertig jetzt nehme ich hier direkt
sich der kanal die kommt hier einfach
oben drauf dann könnt ihr die komplette
torte mit der kann das eindecken
weißt du was wir vergessen haben sehe
ich aus wie du weißt was wer wirklich
vergessen haben
ich wollte nämlich in der mitte noch das
loch ausstechen damit wirklich ein
regenbogen wird hier nicht erzählen der
mitte aus aber guck mal so wie hier der
regenbogen was kommt zuerst brot ok dann
legen wir jetzt hier die roten einmal
außen herum und in der mitte anfang
[Gelächter]
kennen sie den moment da steht ist es
als machen wieso sagen das macht man
nicht
aber da mache so ein hifi ok kommen wir
starten mit lila mensch hat will ihn in
die mitte
[Musik]
oje an dem einen smart ist schokolade
müsste den austauschen
ok entschuldigung ist mein vorschlag
[Musik]
was ist die nächste green trinken ich
mir ja frau bist du schnell mal ein
bisschen aufpassen dass der finger
sauber sind reste warum damit die
smarties auch sauber bleiben
man tut ja ich vergaß sie ist doch die
waschmaschine
[Musik]
ja das ist das etwas andere kind
du siehst voll cool hof die mauer gleich
in die wolken
du siehst für kohle aus hast du dich
kostümierter vollkommen sag mal dein
tolles kleid wow wow das ist ja der
hammer ich mache die torte fertig und
dann darfst du sie wird gleich anschauen
ok airlines grad draußen mit ihrer
freundin und ich mache jetzt noch die
cocos welchen drauf also die wolken als
auch hier außen herum und dann ist alles
bunt orte fertig ein regenbogen kuchen
mit vielen bunten smarties mit
schokolade und den werden wir dann
morgen mittag essen zu ihrem geburtstag
morgen früh wird es erstmal überrascht
das machen wir dann immer ganz gerne am
geburtstags morgen mitgesungen hatte mir
wenn ich mache das dann
und ja ich glaube das gefällt jedoch
ganz gut und ich hoffe dass euch dieses
etwas andere back video gefallen hat es
war eher entertainment- als backend wenn
es für mich
ich hoffe für euch war es beides und ja
was gibt es noch zu sagen das rezept
gibt es trotzdem auch cds märkten
natürlich ein super einfaches rezept
schmeckt bestimmt auch morgen ziemlich
gut der kuchen kommt jetzt in den
kühlschrank stecken dann allerdings noch
ein bisschen ab dass er einfach nicht
austrocknet und eben nicht nach
kühlschrank ich weiß aber das kennt aber
ja ich muss alle meine kuchen abdecken
außer wenn sie mit von dollar überzogen
sind dann bitte nicht mehr abdecken
ja ich wünsche euch jedenfalls viel spaß
beim nachbacken und wir sehen uns wieder
bat messbar
[Musik]
so ist glücklich und mama darf ist
aufräumen
ella wenn du alt genug bist kannst du
die küche auf
[Musik]